but first up he's not only the attorney
who represents stormy Daniels
he's Donald Trump's worst nightmare Mike
[Applause]
I want this recorded a lawyer got a
standing ovation yes you are something
of a folk hero now how are you how are
you coping with your newfound fame I
imagine you can't go anywhere well wait
until we actually accomplish something
in the coming months because you know I
think the reason why liberals love you
is n stormy you know who's I think
acquitted herself very well she looks
very credible and she seems like a good
person okay but let's be honest the
whole reason that we're in love with you
and stormy is because we think you guys
are the tip of the spear that's going to
take down Donald Trump it's all about
that no I know she's just your client
and this is one case for you but walk me
through how our dreams can come true you
want you want me to tell you about the
four plays basically well you're working
for a boner is that correct
[Applause]
one porn star joke I promise that's it
but no I mean how does it get from were
you winning a case to Donald Trump
leaving the White House or Canada well I
mean I think we're gonna get an
opportunity to depose Michael Cohen and
the president within the next 60 to 90
days and I think that what we've seen
bill is the dominoes have already
started to fall and I truly believe that
this is the Achilles heel of the
president he has trusted a [ __ ] with
his innermost with his innermost secrets
and and and the problem the problem is
is that he has surrounded himself in his
adult life with people that are
incompetent and the chickens are going
to come home to roost but okay I'm not a
lawyer to pose does that mean you is
that when like a guy serves you no that
means you raise your right hand you know
but like how does that how do you
actually make Donald Trump show up well
we get a federal judge to order him to
appear for a deposition and and a
federal judge you think will do that I
do I think judge Otero here in Los
Angeles who is one of the best and it
could be any federal judge it could be
well it could be any federal judge but
it's going to be judge Otero in this
case here in Los Angeles because the
because he [ __ ] her here in LA
because no because we filed here in Los
Angeles okay but they sound like I'm
letting the cat out of the bag it was a
bit okay but they did spend some time at
the Beverly Hills Hotel all right
talking about Shark Week okay but and
you think Donald Trump will really show
up I do you do I do I don't you don't I
absolutely well that's gonna set off
what's called a constitutional crisis
well I think he should he should but he
should Donald Trump should hello you
should do a lot of things no I just
don't think and then and then what
happens if he doesn't show up oh it's
gonna be right you know maybe they'll
send out the US Marshals for him you
know what I would look forward to that
if it happen yeah I would my god they
could be fantastic
I dig it'll be good TV but here's what I
think was the it's a big canard that we
hear all the time that the president is
not above the law he certainly is above
the law no he thinks he's above the law
no he is above the law in the sense that
you can't just arrest a guy like Donald
Trump when he is the president you have
to impeach him if I cook a law and you
told me well the only way they can get
you bill is not just to arrest you or
try you in court you have to get 435
people a majority of them to impeach you
and then you have to get another
two-thirds of a hundred people to
convict you I'd say that's quite
different than what the ordinary citizen
has to face I would agree with that but
I think bill that Michael Cohen knows
where almost all the bodies are buried
and I think he is going to sing like a
canary like you
[Applause]
here's the problem you think you'll fold
no I know he's gonna fall Wow because
here's the problem when you have a fixer
you need two things
at least you need a guy that's tough and
you need a guy that is smart
this guy is neither tough nor smart
another big fan of my Coco no you know I
think he's a zero you know you know
Donald Trump totally wishes he had you
[Applause]
here's the problem - I know he can't he
can't buy my client and he can't buy me
no I'm not saying he would I'm just
saying he looks yeah you on TV and goes
what can I get that [ __ ] guy on my
team why am I stuck with this junkyard
dog you're right he's an idiot so so
he'll me how the Sean Hannity thing
leads to anything and also so Michael
Cohen was Sean Hannity's lawyer but he
denies that and says I didn't understand
this at all when he said I slipped him
$10 once by the way I think I think I
think Sean overpaid by $9
[Applause]
would you not be terribly insulted if
somebody slipped you $10 and said could
I have some legal advice I mean I give
the valet 20 you get what you pay for I
know but what does that mean so that
means that they had a real contractor it
doesn't I don't know well wondered why
did he say that and what does it mean it
where's that guy here's what I think I
think that when the documents actually
come out and there are documents there's
no question in my mind there are
documents with Sean Hannity's name on
them the extent of that relationship
when it finally surfaces I think will be
very embarrassing to Sean Hannity and
you don't think Michael Cohen destroyed
evidence before you that the raid
happened well I think actually the
reason why they were able to get the
warrants is because they had him under
electronic surveillance beforehand and
Michael Cohen did it you know it he
didn't realize it and I think the basis
ultimately the American people will
learn that the basis for the warrants
was the fact that the FBI and the US
Attorney's Office had reasonably that
Michael Cohen was undertaking efforts to
destroy documents I think that's what's
gonna come out okay well I I just worry
I see all this giddiness on MSNBC about
all this and I just worry that it's
gonna get to a certain point and then
Donald Trump is just gonna go I either
pardoned everybody or I'm not showing up
and then it comes to nothing but my
other worry about it is that it's taking
a lot of energy away from real issues do
you ever worry about that I know you
have your own case to worry about but
well I think I think the cover-up in
line to the American people is always a
real issue
yes but it's it's actually not what
polls say people care about they care
about health care which doesn't get a
lot of coverage they care about the tax
cut which doesn't get a lot of coverage
because they're all chasing stories like
this I'm not saying you should stop
doing what you're doing well that's good
because we're not yeah no I think it's
great what you're doing and I also think
it's great that you have allowed a porn
star to be shown to the American public
as a real person because you know porn
stars strippers playmates cheerleaders
we found out how what a rotten light
they have
these are the last people it's okay to
[ __ ] on in America you know men can't
admit they know them women certainly
aren't going to defend them so what
someone out of July you've done a good
deal and and what about the future for
you in politics do you think you would
ever want to get into the ring I mean
obviously when you get a standing
ovation well as as you know there's a
small matter that I'm presently focused
on right but you know we'll see how that
goes and I'll tell you what if at the
end of that you decide that that makes
sense for me I'll do it
[Applause]